we're joined now by Trisha scenic the MP
for Richmond a key ally of Boris Johnson
so on tips for a cabinet job he becomes
Prime Minister you might see this face
and I just want to start with those
comments by Nicola Sturgeon she was
responding to what the leader of the SMP
in Westminster had said about Boris
Johnson that he's effectively racist we
can just see what Nicola Sturgeon said
in that interview voice Johnson has made
averting races comments you can
criticize the burka without being deeply
offensive some of the things he said
about black people
I wouldn't even repeat because I don't
think is appropriate to do so what do
you make of what my custodians that well
Sophie first of all I personally would
be sitting here supporting Boris if I
thought he was racist and so something I
care very deeply about and when you look
at the context of that article about the
burqa you know first of all an
independent panel looked at it and they
described it as in the round being
respectful and tolerant and of course we
were going to take particular comments
out of context but the article was
making a very liberal argument about the
right of women to choose what they would
like to wear and she's and at the time
when other European countries you
nuclear surgeons very very fond of us
being connected closer to know they were
going around banning the burqa and here
was Boris making an argument that women
shouldn't be banned they should be able
to make that choice for themselves and
she's also talking about some of the
things he said about black people and I
believe she's referring to a telegraph
column in 2002 yes quite a long time ago
admittedly where he was washing up Tony
Blair they say he shortly after the
Congo no doubt the ak-47s will fall
silent and the pangas will stop their
hacking of human flesh and the tribal
Warriors will all break out in
watermelon smiles well I haven't back to
your article but the broad point I'd say
is Boris's very clearly apologized for
any offence that he's caused through any
of the thousands and thousands of
articles he's written over a very long
journalistic career anything this is
someone who does have a particular way
of communicating which does seem to work
you know he's won two elections in a
place which people thought conservatives
couldn't win he won a referendum
campaign that people thought was not
possible to win and he's able to do
those things because he has a way of
engaging the public and it's because he
speaks in a way that they understand
that's direct that gets through to them
and although you know of course he's
gonna apologize for the comments that
he's made I don't think it's right that
he should become this cookie cutter
politician who
doesn't have that great connection with
the public and engages them and talks
them in a way that they resonate with
clearly as we can see from his track
record I mean there's been a lot of
focus as well on a story that's
dominated the papers over the last
couple of days something that we would
again mean speaking some other guess
about the police being called to the
flat that Boris Johnson shares with his
girlfriend does that story why are you
well I think the thing we do know as you
said is that the police were called and
of course that's something that people
are gonna be highly interested in but
then let's just look at that the police
were called to an incident and what did
they say they said everybody was safe
everybody was well there was no concerns
that the officers had and there was no
cause for any further action and given
that's what the police have said and
it's clear a private incident I wasn't
there you weren't there I think we
should just leave it at that it is
having according to one poll today a bit
of an impact though are you talking
about Boris Johnson's record in London
let's just have a quick look at a poll
that the men on Sunday have published
today this is by servation they asked
who would be the best Prime Minister and
in the days since that incident Jeremy
Hunt has leapfrogged Boris Johnson
thirty percent compared to 29% now
crucially this is among all voters among
members the polls still finds that Boris
Johnson is more popular but it matters
doesn't it what everyone thinks of
course it matters what everybody thinks
because I think Boris Ranjan could be a
prime minister for the entirety of the
UK and I think he'll do a very good job
of that I think of everybody look polls
appalls people react to you know events
by the day what we've seen is he has a
track record of winning and he has track
court of winning even when the polls
said at the beginning of the contest he
wasn't going to win his first race in
London I think the Conservatives were 17
points behind and he managed to pull off
a victory the referendum I mean nobody
thought that leave without a win he led
that referendum so I think when push
comes to shove his track record speaks
for itself and that's cuz he's a
fantastic campaigner and he has a great
set of ideas of about spreading
educational opportunity for everybody
infrastructure investment to make sure
that all parts of our country share in
our prosperity it's important to me as a
northern MP and I you know people talk
about that they feel it I think Boris
connects with that and he will have a
message to those people that will make
them think yes you know here's someone
who can deliver for us as he did in
London and I want to back him now you
voted to leave the EU I think I might
doing and what's Boris Johnson told you
about his plans
because there are some people who look
at the range of opinion that he's
attracted in concert to party and think
how on earth is he gonna have a brexit
policy that keeps Matt Hancock happy in
the one corner and Steve Baker happy in
the other what's he said to you well
first of all I don't think it's a bad
thing that he has attracted support from
all wings of the party I think that's
absolutely the what you should be
looking for in the next prime minister
that's the job that they have to do the
fact that he's been able to do that is a
good thing and I think he said the same
thing to me that he said to everybody
and I think this is where in contrast to
some of the other candidates that who
have had slightly different positions
over time it was absolute clarity he
said the same thing is that we will
leave the European Union on the 31st of
October that's his express will and he
will work very hard to deliver back a
stand guarantee what do you said it's
very clearly he is prepared to walk away
without a deal if that's what it takes
will he do it yeah of course he will do
it that he said crystal clear that he
will do it and and it's right that he
does prepare for that but he's also said
that's not his preference his preference
is not to walk away without a deal his
preference is to renegotiate with our
European friends and allies find a
constructive way to leave but it's
absolutely right and responsible that we
do prepare for no deal in order to
maximize our hand at a negotiating table
and make sure that we're best prepared
and he'll do that with conviction and I
think that's what the British people
deserve someone fighting very hard for
us in Brussels but determined to deliver
on the will of the referendum and get us
out of the EU by the end of October
there's been a bit of consternation
among some of your colleagues about
comments that Boris Johnson made about
renegotiating within the implementation
period I think but just about have time
to quickly show you what David Livington
David Addington has said that's the
wrong one there we go the implementation
period is actually part of the
withdrawal agreement noddle x8 equals no
withdrawal agreement equals no
implementation period and he is wrong
there isn't he but there's a range of
different ways one could leave one is
with the existing withdrawal agreement
but this agreement that's three times so
we'd really need a different way to
leave it could be the this withdrawal
agreement with changes to the backstop
which is an obvious place to start
you can't renegotiate within the
implementation period if there's no deal
can you because well what you will be
renegotiating during an implementation
period if that's where we end up is the
exact form of the future relationship
and that's something that Boris has been
very clear about he wants to have a
future relationship with the EU where of
course there are friends
but we must have control over our
borders our laws our trading
relationships and those are all the
things a detail of which we can work out
during an implementation period and
Boris has been very clear he will
deliver on that when when we get to that
point okay and just finally you once
said in an interview that you wanted to
be a Jedi Knight I mean obviously you
might have to readjust your expectations
slightly but what job would you like in
no Boris Johnson Kevin no it's not a
conversation I've had with him I don't
think there is a minister first off
there's no Minister for Star Wars that
I'm aware of but if if that job can be
created I'd love to do funnily enough
was actually listening at the Royal
Albert Hall yesterday to a great Star
Wars concert which was brilliant with my
kids but no no I thought conversation
I've had with him one thing I think we
do know is that as he did as Mayor of
London he built a fantastic team around
and some of them are in Parliament today
some of his deputy mayor's colleagues of
mine they've been on your show Kip
Malthouse James cleverly they helped him
get crime down and I'm sure he will put
that team together again and do that
everybody and thank you very much for
being on the program today a really
scenic